sur public sénat
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre cet après-midi
un débat sur un véritable phénomène de
société l'obésité aujourd'hui en france
16 9% à des adultes sont obèses
ce phénomène touche également les
enfants puisque 3,5 pour cent des
enfants sont aujourd'hui obèses en
france soit quatre fois plus qu'en 1960
l'obésité peine aujourd'hui être reconnu
comme une vraie maladie
les politiques de prévention successives
sont jugées décevantes dans un rapport
de l'opecst selon l'office parlementaire
d'évaluation des choix scientifiques et
technologiques
pourtant il existe des pistes
prometteuses de recherche qui
permettrait un traitement plus efficace
de la maladie tout de suite dans deux
directions l'hémicycle du sénat
poursuivre ce débat très bonne après
midi à tous
l'ordre du jour appelle le débat sur
l'état de la recherche en matière
d'obésité
la parole est à madame brigitte bout au
nom de l'office parlementaire
d'évaluation des choix scientifiques et
technologiques
c'est quoi
bassil
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je ne peux
m'exprimer au nom du premier
vice-président de monsieur bruno sido
qu'il n'est pas présent aujourd'hui il
est retenu par d'autres choses de
l'office parlementaire
je ne vais donc pouvoir m'exprimer qu'en
tant que vice présidente de l'office
parlementaire
il faut se féliciter d'avoir adopté une
réforme constitutionnelle autorisant
régulièrement des débats de ce type
cela permet à l'office de mettre en
avant les applications scientifiques des
problèmes de société il l'a fait à
l'occasion d'un débat sur les
nanotechnologies puis d'un débat sur les
dangers présumés des lignes à haute
tension sur la santé aujourd'hui il
s'agit de faire le point sur l'état de
la recherche concernant un fléau social
qui progresse lentement mais de façon
inéluctable
l'obésité en 2009 l'office avait
organisé une audition publique sur
l'état de la recherche dans ce domaine
avec l'intention non seulement de faire
le point sur les un point de l'état de
l'art mais aussi d'étudier la façon dont
les avancées de la recherche française
qui était très prometteuse dans ce
domaine se diffusant le corps social
plus précisément vers l'ensemble des
acteurs de la santé à la suite de cette
audition publique
il a été décidé de me confier une étude
dont je vous présente aujourd'hui les
conclusions
celle ci repose sur un travail
d'investigation que je pense assez
complet puisque deux cent trente-quatre
personnes ont été auditionnées
le nombre de propositions neuf au total
est volontairement réduit pour rester
réaliste mais il est suffisant pour
offrir un plan obésité cohérent reposant
sur deux axes la prévention de l'essor
de cette maladie et l'organisation de
l'effort de recherche
sur l'obésité je précise que l'aspect
organisation des soins avaient été
volontairement exclus du champ de
l'étude le rappelle le rapport d'abord
considéré les politiques de prévention
de l'obésité
en effet puisque les connaît pas de
traitement totalement efficace lorsque
l'obésité est installé il est de toute
première importance de la prévenir
hélas jusqu'à présent les politiques de
prévention se sont révélées décevantes
ce relatif échec s'explique en partie
par la difficulté d'élucider les causes
de l'obésité qui sont nombreuses
variables en fonction des individus mais
il provient également de la mise en
place de politique résultant de la
confrontation d'intérêts contradictoires
que sur des résultats scientifiques
validées par des expérimentations de
terrain je me suis donc efforcée dans
mon étude de rassembler les données
scientifiques en prend en compte pour
mener une politique de prévention la
plus efficace possible
je vous présenterai donc brièvement
quatre séries de mesures qui me
paraissent indispensables pour réaliser
une politique de prévention efficace une
première observation
le gradient socioculturel de l'obésité
est très fort particulièrement pour les
femmes et pour les enfants
la catégorie socioprofessionnelle c'est
à dire le nom le niveau de revenu et le
niveau d'éducation sont trois
déterminants majeurs de l'obésité agir
sur ces trois points constituerait un
levier puissant de prévention la
deuxième conclusion concernant les
politiques de prévention consiste à
privilégier
les mesures modifiant l'environnement en
effet de nombreuses études scientifiques
ont montré l'insuffisance des politiques
visant à modifier les comportements
individuels
ceci en raison de l' influence
prépondérante des environnements
matériels sociaux et culturels
une politique de prévention efficace
doit donc s'accompagner d' intervention
visant à promouvoir un environnement qui
facilite l'adoption sans effort de
comportement reconnu favorables à la
santé
concrètement je suis pour la suppression
de la publicité télévisée pour les
produits alimentaires transformés avant
pendant et après les programmes jeunesse
et sur les chaînes destinées à la
jeunesse
j'estime aussi nécessaire de supprimer
l'exonération de la taxe sur la
publicité pour les produits alimentaires
manufacturés et les boissons avec ajout
de sucre
ma troisième proposition vise à élaborer
un plan de prévention
reposant sur cinq piliers premièrement
une gouvernement une gouvernance inter
ministériel susceptibles de disposer
d'un pouvoir d'impulsion et de décision
avec des moyens financiers et humains
adaptés aux missions qui lui seront
confiées
un comité scientifique visant à recenser
les les acquis scientifiques à prendre
en compte dans l'élaboration d'un plan
global de lutte contre l'obésité est
emmené assurer la transmission aux
acteurs du système de santé
enfin des messages de prévention pour
l'élaboration de normes sociales
favorables à la santé et influençant les
systèmes de représentation quatrièmement
des actions locales en direction des
populations à risque
et cinquièmement
une évaluation systématique et régulière
de toutes les mesures prises la
quatrième proposition ainsi sur la
nécessité de développer la prévention
précoce de nombreuses études montrent
que le développement de l'obésité chez
le jeune adulte est influencé par des
exposition prénatale périnatale et
pendant même la petite enfance
indépendamment de son hygiène ultérieure
de vie par conséquent il est
indispensable de mettre en place une
prévention de l'obésité dès la grossesse
afin de repérer très tôt les éventuelles
situations à risque et d'instaurer une
vigilance accrue pendant les premières
années de la vie comme je les dis
précédemment
si un plan de d'obésité doit reposer
d'abord sur la prévention
il convient également d'intensité les
efforts de recherche des causes de
l'obésité au cours de mes investigations
j'ai constaté que la recherche française
sur l'obésité et de grande qualité
elle privilégie les aspects fondamentaux
notamment moléculaire et génétique de
même un accent particulier mais est mis
sur l'analyse physiologiques des
pathologies liées à l'obésité tels que
le diabète de type 2 l'hypertension la
stéatose hépatique lassus lawn
l'insulinorésistance et l'hyperlipidémie
etc
d'une manière générale les aspects
comportementaux sociaux économiques et
environnementaux ainsi que ceux liés aux
neurosciences et au marketing sont
beaucoup moins soutenu financièrement
or la recherche dans ces domaines est
indispensable pour développer des
nouveaux outils d'étude
pour la compréhension des comportements
et du métabolisme et pour déterminer des
stratégies plus efficaces les études
trencin translationnelle doivent
également être encouragés afin de mieux
comprendre les facteurs de
prédisposition aux complications de
l'obésité et mettre au point des
biomarqueurs précoces de la transition
vers l'état pathologique
telles sont les principales conclusions
de mon rapport sur lequel j'aimerais
connaître votre sentiment
parallèlement à cette étude le 21 mai
2010 le président de la république lancé
à l'occasion de la journée européenne
sur l'obésité un plan de trois ans
visant à enrayer la progression de cette
maladie
140 millions d'euros devaient être
consacrés à ce plan dont le pilote
désigné n'est autre que le professeur
arnaud de pas devant chef du service de
nutrition à l'hôpital de la pitié
salpêtrière et l'un des plus grands
spécialistes de l'obésité au niveau
national et international
la lettre de mission du professeur
arnaud basdevant présenté trois axes
d'action le premier axe porté sur la
recherche afin d'animer et d'intensifier
l'effort de recherche
il était prévu à l'instar de ce qui
avait été fait pour le plan les maires
de créer une fondation de coopération
scientifique associant l'alliance
nationale pour les sciences de la vie et
de la santé aviesan à des partenaires
publics et privés
le deuxième axe porté sur la prévention
il visait à faciliter l'application des
recommandations existantes en améliorant
l'alimentation scolaire la restauration
collective et la restauration solidaire
et en développement
en développant l'activité physique pour
la santé à l'école
le dernier axe porté sur la prise en
charge et insisté sur la nécessité de
développer une prise en charge de
qualité sur tout le territoire y compris
l'outre-mer en apportant également une
attention particulière aux populations
fragiles le lancement de ce plan
présidentiel prenait acte du fait que la
france est loin d'être épargnée par la
progression de l'obésité
la prévalence de l'obésité chez les
adultes augmente de 5,9 pour cent par an
en france selon la dernière enquête
nationale nutrition santé réalisée en
2006 16 9% de la population adulte est
obèse 3,5 pour cent des enfants sont
obèses et quatre fois plus qu'en 2000
qu'en 1960
c'est quand même une évolution qui me
paraît fort importante
en outre cette évolution est inquiétante
car non seulement de plus en plus
d'adultes deviennent obèses mais s mais
aussi parce qu'ils le sont de plus en
plus jeunes et souvent au stade de
l'enfance
pourtant si les attentes restent fortes
pour mettre en place une politique
cohérente de lutte contre l'obésité
les espoirs suscités par le plan
présidentiel reste pour l'instant déçu
en effet qu'est devenu le plan
présidentiel lancé il y a un an
jusqu'à présent aucune information n'a
filtré ce qui n'est pas forcément bon
signe
par ailleurs de nombreuses
interrogations demeurent sur la mise en
oeuvre des 23 mesures retenues puisqu'en
pratique le plan obésité ne dispose pas
d'un pilote clairement identifiés avec
un réel pouvoir de décision ainsi les
mesures de prévention sont dispersés au
sein de trois plans à savoir le
programme national pour l'alimentation
liger par le ministère de l'agriculture
le plan national nutrition centre et
santé organisée par le ministère de la
santé et le plan obésité de nature
interministériel comment se fera
l'articulation des mesures de prévention
entre ces trois plans en outre il
semblerait qu'un volet important du plan
obésité soit dans l'impasse la création
de la vie sans à des partenaires publics
et privés
or la seule création d'une telle
fondation permettrait de dégager des
moyens financiers suffisants pour lancer
un programme de recherche sous l'obésité
à la hauteur de l'enjeu que représente
cette maladie
en conclusion je souhaiterais rappeler
que si certaines mesures ne peuvent être
prises que dans le cade a plein
d'ensemble sur l'obésité
d'autres pourraient être adoptées dès
maintenant dans la mesure où les faits
sont scientifiquement avérées je veux
illustrer mes propos par deux exemples
j'ai déjà rappelé la nécessité de
limiter la publicité alimentaire en
direction des enfants
j'évoquerai aussi toute la communication
trompeuse qui porte sur la peu
possibilité de perdre rapidement
beaucoup de poids grâce à certaines
formes de régimes amaigrissants ou grâce
à l'option l'absortion de préparation à
base d'herbes ou de médicaments cette
offre n'est pas assez réglementée vous
aurez compris madame le ministre de la
question de l'obésité me tient
particulièrement à coeur et ce depuis
des décennies comme le prouve mon
engagement dans le projet fleurbaix
laventie ville santé dont j'étais maire
de fleurbaix lancé en 1992 et qui est là
haut
à l'origine du plan qui programme epode
ensemble prévenons l'obésité des enfants
par conséquent
je me réjouis que l'office est proposé
d'inscrire à l'ordre du jour du sénat
un débat sur l'état de la recherche en
matière d'obésité
j'espère que ces débats contribuera à
sensibiliser l'ensemble l'ensemble des
parlementaires sont pas très nombreux
sur l'importance de cette question et
permettra d'accélérer la mise en oeuvre
du plan obésité voulu par le président
de la république et de lui donner tous
les moyens humains et financiers
nécessaires à sa réussite
je vous remercie merci merci mes chers
collègues
c'est là dans la suite du débat du débat
la parole est aux orateurs de groupe
je ne la parole à madame annie david
pour le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen sénateurs du parti de gauche
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues le rapport de notre
collègue brigitte bout je ne voyais plus
réalisé dans le cadre donc de l'opex
concernant l'obésité est très instructif
et riche de propositions vous le
rappeliez madame le rapporteur et nous
interroge sur ce que les scientifiques
considèrent être la première épidémie
non infectieuses entre 1997 et 2009 la
proportion de personnes en situation
d'obésité a presque doublé en france au
point que 14,5 pour cent de la
population de notre pays est considéré
comme obèse
elle devrait atteindre 20% à l'horizon
2020 il s'agit donc bien là d'un
véritable enjeu de santé publique dans
la mesure où l'obésité entraîne
l'apparition de maladies importantes
pouvant conduire à une morbidité précoce
on soulignera par exemple que 80 % des
personnes atteintes de diabète de type 2
sont en surpoids ou que 23% des
infarctus du myocarde peuvent être
imputés au surpoids et à l'obésité mais
circonscrire les conséquences de
l'obésité a un aspect seulement médicale
c'est oublier que l'obésité emporte
également des conséquences du point de
vue social et financier social d'abord
car les images stéréotypées du corps
idéal
les pressions sociales et commerciales
pèsent sur les personnes en surpoids et
nuisent à leur épanouissement personnel
économique ensuite dans la mesure où les
dépenses de santé liées à l'obésité
atteignent en france atteignaient en
france en 2002 3 3 milliards d'euros et
les chiffres ont dû augmenter depuis on
estime ainsi que dans les pays
industrialisés les dépenses de santé
publique liés à la lutte ou aux
conséquences de l'obésité représentent
jusqu'à 7 % des dépenses totales
malgré ce constat que personne ne
conteste force est de constater que
l'obésité progressé que les
recommandations formulées par les
scientifiques comme par les politiques
n'ont pas été suivies d'actes on sait
pourtant aujourd'hui vous l'avez
souligné madame goutte que les causes de
l'obésité sont diverses et
complémentaires
on doit dès lors parler d'obésité au
pluriel d'une manière schématique on
peut considérer qu'il existe trois
grandes familles d'obésité tout d'abord
celle reposant sur des facteurs
génétiques
certains gènes peu nombreux ont un
impact important sur la corpulence et le
pourcentage ou la distribution régionale
de la masse grasse ensuite celle
reposant sur des facteurs
endocrinologique tels que les
dérèglements hormonaux ce qui devrait
conduire à favoriser la recherche où
l'avait d'ailleurs dit dans notre pays
madame doute la recherche à avance bien
mais je rajouterais la recherche
également portant sur certaines familles
de médicaments et enfin celle reposant
sur les facteurs environnementaux et
sociaux celle sur laquelle je voudrais
m'attarder un instant même si les liens
entre précarité et obésité sont
complexes
ils sont indéniables on sait on ne vous
le rappeler que la prévalence de
l'obésité est deux fois plus élevée
parmi les ouvriers que parmi les cadres
supérieurs
cela résulte naturellement du fait que
dans les foyers les plus pauvres la part
des ressources consacrées à
l'alimentation est souvent réduite aux
produits de premiers prix et de première
nécessité la diversité est un luxe que
de nombreuses familles ne peuvent
s'offrir
dans ce contexte le panier essentielles
proposées par le gouvernement mais dans
la composition et d'essai à la
discrétion des enseignes ressemble plus
à un gadget cas une réponse efficace et
appropriée et le slogan manger cinq
fruits et légumes par jour s'apparente
plus à une provocation qu'un véritable
outil de communication
en réalité ce panier essentiel garanti
aux grandes enseignes le bénéfice d'un
label et permet de contourner
simultanément deux débats capitaux celui
de la flambée des prix alimentaires est
celui de l'explosion de la précarité
or c'est bien une politique globale de
lutte contre la pauvreté qui permettra
de réduire les cas d'obésité liés aux
déterminants sociaux
vous l'avez rappelé la grande
distribution profite donc allègrement de
cette opération comme le dénonçait
l'association ufc que choisir
je cite les consommateurs ne bénéficient
toujours pas de la baisse des prix des
matières premières agricoles
l'amélioration de la qualité
nutritionnelle des
lui transformé reste un voeu pieux
comment admettre qu'on nous serve un
dispositif aussi peu ambitieux par
ailleurs on sait que l'industrie
agroalimentaire par notamment les plats
préparés qu'elle propose et qui sont
trop gras et trop sucrés participent à
l'augmentation du phénomène dit de mal
bouffe
or cela n'est pas étranger à la
dégradation des rythmes et de
l'organisation du travail
il est pour le moins contradictoire
d'attendre des parents qui jouent
pleinement leur rôle en termes
d'éducation à l' équilibre alimentaire
ou de préparation des repas tout en
organisant la dégradation des conditions
de travail
en imposant par exemple le travail du
dimanche les temps partiels ou encore
les horaires décalés il serait en outre
souhaitable que dans un futur proche
l'utilisation de l'huile de palme soit
interdite du fait de ses impacts
négatifs sur la santé comme sur
l'environnement aussi une souscrivant à
la proposition de rendre obligatoire sur
la face avant du produit
les informations nutritionnelles le
concernant tout comme nous souhaitons
que notre législation nationale soit
plus rigoureuses afin que les
industriels à porte auprès de la fsa
la preuve du caractère allégée de leurs
produits ou de leurs effets positifs sur
l'organisme
tout comme vous madame la rapporteure
nous considérons qu'il est impératif de
protéger le jeune public du matraquage
marque marketing dont ils sont victimes
de la part des industries
agroalimentaires ainsi l' ufc que
choisir encore nous alertait il ya déjà
six ans en ces termes sur les 217 spots
alimentaires ciblant les enfants relevés
pendant 15 jours sur les plus grandes
chaînes de télévision à l'heure des
émissions enfantines 89 % concernent des
produits très sucrés ou gras
nous avons d'ailleurs à l'initiative de
ma collègue evelyne didier déposé une
proposition de loi relative à la
protection des enfants et les
adolescents face aux effets de la
publicité télévisuelle dans laquelle
nous dénonçons notamment que cette
pression publicitaire peut avoir des
effets directs sur la santé physique des
enfants au premier rang desquels se
trouve
l'obésité enfin comment éluder le rôle
que devrait jouer la prévention et l'on
voit bien que l'école au sens large
devrait être le lieu pivot de
l'application des différentes politiques
de prévention en faveur de la lutte
contre l'obésité avec quelques six
millions d'enfants qui fréquentent les
cantines
il est de notre responsabilité de
permettre que les menus soient plus
qualitatif du point de vue nutritionnel
et plus équilibrée n'oublions pas que le
repas pris dans le cadre scolaire est
souvent le seul répondant aux
préconisations de la haute autorité de
santé mais aussi le seul prix par bon
nombre de ces jeunes pour autant
beaucoup d'efforts restent à faire
c'est pourquoi nous faisons nôtre la
proposition de christophe hébert
président de l'association nationale des
directeurs de restauration municipale
qui déclarait en 2007
à l'école on doit apprendre à manger
comme on apprend à lire
malheureusement nous partageons
également son constat il existe un
manque d'intervention de professionnels
dans le milieu scolaire
le point essentiel c'est le taux
d'encadrement la présence de personnels
formés en cantine aux côtés des enfants
c'est dans ce sens que j'avais interrogé
en 2008 votre gouvernement sur
l'évolution de la semaine du goût qui
existe déjà dans nos établissements
scolaires en la faisant et vous évoluez
et en la complétant de la notion d'
équilibre alimentaire puisque dans le
cadre du programme national nutrition
santé l'une de vos missions
ou en tout cas celle du ministère de la
santé et bien la promotion d'une bonne
nutrition
mais il faut aller bien au delà et
renforcer également la médecine scolaire
spécialement dédié aux enfants
adolescents et aux cadres éducatifs
c'est à dire renoncer aux suppressions
de postes qui sont pratiqués au point
qu'il n'y a plus actuellement que 1200
médecins scolaires pour 12 millions
d'élèves
vous le voyez mes chers collègues la
lutte contre l'obésité ne peut pas
reposer sur la seule bonne volonté elle
nécessite la mobilisation de moyens
humains et financiers que la rgpp et la
politique actuelle de votre gouvernement
madame la ministre ne permettent pas
aussi pour que l'obésité soit enfin
considéré comme cet enjeu de santé
publique que tout le monde appelle de
ses voeux
madame la ministre je vous demande
quelles mesures vous êtes
à mettre en oeuvre merci merci mme asha
collègues
la parole est à monsieur raymond couderc
au titre de l'union pour un mouvement
populaire
madame la présidente madame le ministre
mes chers collègues
madame la vice présidente de l'office
mes chers collègues l'obésité est plus
particulièrement l'obésité infantile est
devenue un enjeu de santé publique
majeur dans la plupart des pays
industrialisés
en france le surpoids et on l'a dit
touche actuellement près d'un enfant sur
cinq c'est l'étude tns qui révélait dont
trois et demi pour cent d'enfants obèses
il est aujourd'hui américain enfants
obèses risque fortement de le rester à
l'âge adulte entraînant une augmentation
considérable de maladies associées comme
les maladies cardiovasculaires et le
diabète de type 2 et diminuant de 13 ans
son espérance de vie
la prise en charge restant difficile et
encore peut évaluer
il est fondamental de prévenir et de
prendre en charge dès le plus jeune âge
la prise de poids excessive des enfants
je ne suis ni médecin ni chercheurs dans
le domaine de la médecine ou de la
biologie mais je peux par contre vous
parler d'expériences vécues de retour
d'expérience puisque je suis
actuellement le président des villes
epode ensemble prévenons l'obésité des
enfants qui regroupe plus de 200
communes au total ainsi que des
expériences qui sont parrainés en
belgique en espagne en grèce en
australie et même au mexique
je dois rendre hommage d'ailleurs à
l'expérience des précurseurs de
fleurbaix laventie avec brigitte bout
qui a montré le chemin avant que le
programme epode ne soit engagé avec
d'abord dix villes témoins dix villes
d'expérience et puis ensuite aujourd'hui
c'est cet élargissement
l'objectif du programme epode c'est
d'aider les familles à modifier modifié
en profondeur et durablement leur mode
de vie en développant grâce à la
mobilisation de tous les acteurs locaux
une offre de proximité conforme aux
recommandations du programme national
nutrition santé
est axé principalement sur d'abord une
alimentation équilibrée diversifiée
abordable et plaisante au niveau
familial la pratique d'activités
physiques pour tous intégrés dans le
quotidien et l'encouragement à
développer un environnement local
favorable à ses bonnes habitudes
le programme repose sur quatre piliers
d'abord un engagement fort des
politiques au niveau local et au niveau
national et c'est le cas
ensuite une organisation professionnelle
avec une expertise en marketing social
ensuite un financement durable assurée
par un partenariat public-privé reposant
sur des règles très claires et enfin une
expertise scientifique pour l'évaluation
d'abord une démarche de prévention et
excusez moi de prendre le cas
particulier de la ville dont je suis
maire béziers le choix a été fait de
promouvoir une approche globale de la
question de l'obésité infantile souvent
édifié à partir des écoles la démarche
de prévention c'est peu et peu à peu
étendu à tous les aspects de la vie
communale à savoir les familles les
associations sportives et sociales les
institutions les acteurs privés et ainsi
plusieurs projets ont été réalisés
ainsi chaque année depuis 2006 plus de
1000 enfants participent à la randonnée
des écoles en partenariat avec
l'éducation nationale
quatre parcours de 8 à 16 km sont
proposés avec découverte du patrimoine
et sensibilisation à travers un pique
nique équilibré également une fois par
an est organisé un petit déjeuner
pédagogique dans plusieurs écoles de la
ville les enfants et leurs parents sont
conviés pour partager un petit déjeuner
avec réunion d'information faites par
une diététicienne des ateliers
sensoriels sont mis en place pour
permettre l'éveil aux différents goûts
menés dans les maternelles et les
crèches y compris il concerne aussi un
centre pour enfants handicapés et enfin
un atelier a été proposé aux familles
défavorisées dont on sait aujourd'hui
qu'elles sont particulièrement à risque
dans ce domaine afin de les conseiller
pour gérer leurs achats
notamment en lisant plus attentivement
les étiquettes en repérant les graisses
et sucres cachés des propositions de
menus diététiques leur sont aussi faites
deuxième point c'est la démarche de
prise en charge au delà de l'approché
globale a aussi été mis en place dans ma
ville un programme spécifique de prise
en charge des enfants détecté comme
étant en surpoids
chaque année à peu près 12 cents élèves
sont des sont détectés du moins sont
examinées la campagne d'information
touche les enfants de 0 à 25 ans
dépistage scolaire et réaliser une prise
en charge médicale de la surchage
pondérale des enfants et des adolescents
dépistés par une association propre
santé et par le collège des médecins du
biterrois qui rassemble 150 médecins il
s'agit de prendre en charge les enfants
qui sont dépistés essentiellement sur le
plan diététique et si besoin
psychologique également et notamment au
niveau de l'image du corps que peuvent
en avoir les enfants environ 535 enfants
ont ainsi été accompagnée depuis 2006
cette prise en charge chez ces derniers
je le disais avec l'aide des médecins de
ville a permis une baisse de leur
corpulence moyenne allant de -10 % chez
324 enfants suivi en 2007 jusqu'à -40 9%
chez les 256 enfants suivis en 2010
enfin l'accompagnement des enfants en
situation d'obésité
une donnée n'était pas encore prise en
compte dans ce programme et cela malgré
les bons résultats aussi un second
projet très récent a été mis en place
récemment le projet expérimental lipome
axe consiste en une réadaptation à
l'activité physique des enfants dépistés
obèses dans le cadre d'epode est suivi
par krok santé en collaboration avec
service des sports le centre médico
sportif
plus précisément il s'agit là de 12
enfants qui ont été coachés pendant huit
semaines par un éducateur sportif
stagiaires dans master
activité physique adaptée en lien avec
le service des sports de la vie les
résultats préliminaires semblent montrer
dans la plupart des cas la mort ce d'une
baisse significative de la masse grasse
de ses enfants au bénéfice de la masse
maigre et donc d'une prise de muscle au
détriment de la masse grasse cette étude
prometteuse mérite donc d'être continuer
et analysés sur une plus grande
population puisqu'elle semble apporter
quelques réponses positives aux
problèmes que peut poser l'obésité
infantile
le programme prévention epode par ses
149 actions en 2009 a ainsi réussi à
toucher
douze mille personnes sur la ville de
béziers soit par ces actions le
dépistage qu'elle propose la
communication directe
il serait donc intéressant d'étendre ce
type d'action à toutes les villes afin
de mettre à disposition des familles des
médecins et des élus un outil de
promotion du sport et d'une alimentation
saine et variée pour lutter contre les
maladies que peut engendrer l'obésité
des enfants
je vous remercie merci à chaque collègue
la parole est à madame anne marie payet
pour l'union centriste
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues depuis la seconde
guerre mondiale l'europe ne cesse de sa
mairie kaniz et pour le meilleur et pour
le pire en l'occurrence puisqu'il est
question d'obésité ce n'est certainement
pas pour le meilleur
le développement de l'obésité en france
est une réalité de plus en plus
préoccupante
comme l'a très bien rappelé notre
collègue brigitte bout les chiffres
parlent d'eux mêmes et sont frappants
notre pays compte aujourd'hui 16 9 %
d'adultes obèses avec une augmentation
de la prévalence de l'obésité de presque
6% par an 3 5 % des enfants sont obèses
soit quatre fois plus qu'en deux ans
qu'en 1960 tandis que 14 3 % des enfants
sont en surpoids
et encore il ne s'agit là que de
statistiques globales qui ne disent rien
des écarts observable au sein de la
population française écart entre les
sexes et touche deux fois plus les
femmes que les hommes
écart entre catégories
socioprofessionnelles bien sûr écarts
géographiques aussi raison pour laquelle
le problème tient très à coeur car ils
touchent l'outremer et surtout la
réunion dont je suis élu de manière
particulièrement forte en effet l'île de
la réunion ne fait pas exception à
l'épidémie mondiale de l'obésité
considérée par l' oms comme l'épidémie
du siècle dans les différentes études
réalisées localement on observe une
différence nette entre les sexes
fréquence plus élevée du surpoids dans
la population masculine
près de 40 % contre 33 poisson chez les
femmes
en revanche les prévalence de l'obésité
sont sensiblement plus élevé chez les
femmes
contrairement à ce qui est observé dans
les différentes enquêtes nationales
ainsi les prévalences local de l'obésité
sont respectivement d'environ 10 % chez
les hommes et de 20 % chez les femmes en
métropole est la voyais elle avoisine
les 11% chez les hommes comme chez les
femmes
je m'inquiète particulièrement de
l'obésité chez l'enfant en effet la
surcharge pondérale touche 15 à 20% des
enfants à la réunion et la prévalence de
l'obésité infantile a quintuplé en moins
de 20 ans les trois quarts de ses
enfants resteront obèses à l'âge adulte
et connaîtront les complications de
l'obésité la réunion a subi une
évolution rapide des modes de vie qui
définit un contexte propice à la prise
de poids et pas conséquent au
développement de maladies
la nutrition diabète est acheté à
notamment dont l'obésité est l'un des
facteurs de risque bien identifiés le
retentissement de l'obésité est ainsi
important en terme de mortalité et de
morbidité les taux standardisé de
mortalité dû au diabète et à ses
complications et de 62,8 pour cent mille
habitants en guadeloupe 63,3 en
martinique
65,7 en guyane 108,3 à la réunion contre
32 pour cent mille habitants en
métropole
ainsi tous les français ne sont pas
égaux face à l'obésité
un phénomène dont l'impact néfaste et
multiples impacts psychologiques pour
les personnes obèses qui ont du mal à
s'accepter un pacte social pour les
victimes d'une maladie qui sont souvent
stigmatisés impact de santé publique
évidemment les pathologies liées à
l'obésité sont connus et nombreuses
diabète risque cardiovasculaire stéatose
hépatique certains cancers aussi enfin
impact financier évidemment l'obésité
représente un coût de plus en plus
considérable pour l'assurance maladie
dans ces conditions on comprend que
prévenir et traiter l'obésité doit être
une priorité absolue de santé publique
ce qui n'a pas échappé au président de
la république qui a créé en octobre 2009
une commission pour la prévention de
l'obésité dont les recommandations ont
imprégné le programme national nutrition
santé
mais combattre efficacement la maladie
suppose bien sûr de la comprendre d'où
l'enjeu clé de la recherche
j'en profite pour féliciter notre
collègue brigitte bout pour l'excellent
rapport qu'elle a rendu public le 8
décembre dernier pour l'office
parlementaire d'évaluation des choix
scientifiques et technologiques
suite à la saisine de cet office par
notre commission des affaires sociales
sur ce thème un rapport qui al'immense
mérite d'éclairer pour la première fois
le dossier de l'obésité sous l'angle
absolument déterminant de la recherche
le présent débat est la suite logique de
ce travail inédit et compte tenu de
l'enjeu
c'est tout à l'honneur de la haute
assemblée de s'en saisir de la sorte
alors à l'aune des informations
rassemblées et mise en perspective par
le rapport bout quelles conclusions
tirez sur l'état de la recherche en
matière d'obésité que nous avons
beaucoup avancé mais que nous n'avons
pas encore suffisamment avancé nous
avons beaucoup avancé
parce que nous savons désormais que
l'obésité doit être considérée comme une
maladie à part entière une maladie
chronique à la fois complexe et graver
ses principaux mécanismes physiologiques
ont été mises au jour
même si nous avons toujours du mal à
appréhender ses causes et leurs
interactions qui sont nombreuses et
varient en fonction des individus
un constat positif qui me donne
l'occasion de saluer et rendre hommage à
l'extraordinaire travail effectué par
les chercheurs dans des conditions
parfois bien difficile en revanche il
nous reste encore du chemin à parcourir
pour ce que la recherche n'a pas encore
réussi à élaborer des thérapies
permettant de guérir cette maladie
cela a été rappelé tous les médicaments
visant à réduire la prise alimentaire
ont été retirés du marché compte tenu de
leurs effets secondaires
alors que les médicaments jouant sur la
mauvaise absorption des nutriments sont
peu efficaces
à ce jour seule la chirurgie bariatrique
essentiellement le by pass comme on le
dit en français a eu un effet
spectaculaire à la fois en matière de
perte durable de poids et de diminution
de la mentalité
mais la chirurgie bariatrique demeure
une solution qui peut être très
éprouvante sur le plan psychologique
fort de ce constat global une conclusion
s'impose il nous faut aujourd'hui mettre
l'accent sur la prévention
et ce n'est qu'à ce stade de l'analyse
que je me permettrai de faire entendre
une voix un peu alternative par rapport
aux conclusions du rapport de boue le
rapport fait état de résultats modestes
donné par les actions ciblées jusqu'ici
conduite en conséquence il préconise une
approche beaucoup plus globale visant à
réduire les inégalités dans les domaines
de l'emploi du logement de l'éducation
de la santé et des transports comme
levier les plus puissants pour lutter
contre l'obésité
c'est une évidence ce que je crois c'est
que nous ne sommes pas nous ne nous
sommes pas donner les moyens de nos
ambitions en matière de prévention
ciblées de l'obésité autrement dit en
matière d'éducation nutritionnelle
s'attaquer aux distributeurs de boissons
de même qu imposer les messages
publicitaires constitue un premier pas
encourageant mais nous devrions aller au
coeur du problème
nous devrions nous servir des vertus
pédagogiques de l'école pour apprendre
aux enfants à se nourrir ne rien faire
seul
c'est se perpétuer l'inégalité face à
l'obésité par nature l'école a vocation
à enrayer ce type d' inégalités ainsi
nous pensons que l'éducation
nutritionnelle scolaire est une voix a
fortement privilégiée pour lutter
activement contre l'obésité
merci de votre attention merci le chat
collègues
la parole est à madame patricia chien
j'ai pour le groupe socialiste
le seul président madame la présidente
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
selon le m s 1 milliard d'adultes sont
en surpoids
et si rien n'est fait ils seront plus de
1,5 milliard d'ici à 2015 chaque année
2,6 millions de personnes au moins
meurent des conséquences du surpoids ou
de l'obésité en france on compte d'une
augmentation de l'obésité de 5,9 pour
cent par an et celle ci concerne 16 9 %
des adultes
autre constat terrible l'obésité des
enfants est en train d'exploser 3.5
pourcent des enfants sont obèses
aujourd'hui nous avons un taux de
croissance du surpoids comparable à
celui des américains
il faut souligner que deux tiers des
enfants obèses le resteront à l'âge
adulte ils risqueront donc d'avoir des
problèmes cardiovasculaires x 3 des
troubles articulaires
mais souffriront également d'une
certaine stigmatisation en qui entend
engendrera pour eux des problèmes
sociaux nous sommes donc face à une
progression inquiétante car elle porte
sur des individus de plus en plus jeunes
on peut dire qu'actuellement l'obésité
est une véritable épidémie qui frappe
aussi les pays industrialisés que les
pays en voie de développement
ces causes peuvent être très variables
d'une personne à l'autre
on parle même d'obésité au pluriel selon
les études plusieurs facteurs permettent
d'expliquer l'obésité les facteurs
génétiques les facteurs en doc rhino
logique les facteurs environnementaux et
les modifications comportementales tels
que la malbouffe avec une alimentation
trop riche
dans les années 80 le terme malbouffe
désigner la nourriture les fast food
aujourd'hui il désigne davantage
l'alimentation industrielle trop grasse
trop sucrée est trop salée cette
malbouffe est imposé dans nos sociétés
modernes pour différentes raisons et
notamment à cause de l'augmentation des
prix des fruits et légumes frais alors
que les produits gras et sucrés reste
très abordable
le rythme de vie et le manque de temps
font que certains sont amenés à sauter
un repas ou à manger rapidement les
étiquettes nutritionnelles des produits
ne sont pas assez claires la publicité
fait la promotion des produits trop gras
et trop sucrés pour prévenir cette
obésité
nous disposons de différents outils tels
que le dépistage avec le calcul de l'imc
la politique nutritionnelle mangez mieux
bougez plus les actions en milieu
scolaire cependant l'obésité demeure une
maladie que l'on ne sait ni guérir ni
prévenir efficacement
en effet le comportement ces dernières
années ont changé on s'aperçoit
qu'auparavant on pouvait rester mince
tout en absorbant des calories en
abondance cela a été possible car les
activités quotidiennes étaient beaucoup
plus physique
aujourd'hui les populations occidentales
ont tendance à consommer moins de
calories et moins de graisse qu'en 1960
et pourtant et grossistes cela
s'explique par un changement de style de
vie qui devient de plus en plus
sédentaire l'homme moderne est donc
devenu sédentaire c'est la raison pour
laquelle l'un des principaux objectifs
des scientifiques et de découvrir
comment rassasié un individu avec moins
de calories
comment un régime alimentaire peut-il
donc devenir plus rassasiants les
principales pistes actuellement
explorées porte soit sur des aliments à
forte teneur en glucides soit sur la
consommation des protéines en plus ou en
moins grande quantité et en ce qui
concerne l'obésité des enfants
aujourd'hui de nombreux travaux
établissent le lien entre leur surcharge
pondérale et l'allongement du temps
d'inactivité en particulier devant la
télévision
par ailleurs je tiens à souligner ici
que la catégorie socioprofessionnelle le
niveau de revenu le lieu d'habitation
sont des déterminants importants de
l'obésité riches et pauvres ne sont pas
égaux face à l'obésité
le risque pour un enfant d'ouvrier
d'être en surpoids ou obèses reste plus
important que sully en face de cadres
même si il existe actuellement des
outils pour prévenir l'obésité
avant même que c'est simple
n'apparaissent on reste face à un échec
en effet les gestes de prévention axée
sur l'équilibré alimentaire et
l'activité physique ne paraissent pas
être une efficacité suffisante au regard
d'une obésité en constante augmentation
la mise en oeuvre de la charte de
l'industrie alimentaire et des médias
télévisés sur la nutrition
signé en février 2009 a été un échec
en effet le harcèlement publicitaire
continue la charte n'a pas permis de
limiter le matraquage publicitaire pour
les produits gras sucrés ou salés
certaines entreprises font subir un
véritable harcèlement alimentaire aux
enfants qui regardent la télévision en
rentrant de l'école souvent sans
contrôle parental les communication
nutritionnelle demeure sans grande
légimité légitimité scientifique
le contenu éditorial de la diffusion des
programmes éducatifs reste sous la seule
responsabilité de l'industrie
alimentaire et des médias les programmes
éducatifs invisible
le volume de diffusion des programmes
développés par les professionnels de la
nutrition est ridiculement faible au
regard du déferrement publicitaire
quotidien face à cet échec pourquoi
n'impose ton pas la gratuité de la
diffusion des campagnes de l'inp s sur
l'équilibré alimentaire pourquoi
n'imposons pas les tarifs plus
accessibles pour les campagnes des
filières fruits et légumes par ailleurs
il a perdu il apparaît incroyable que le
médiator classé que médicament pour
diabétiques en surpoids a pu également
servir de coupe faim alors que tous les
anorexigènes avait été interdit en effet
le 31 août 1999 le comité des
spécialistes pharmaceutique de l'agencé
européenne pour l'évaluation des
médicaments en a recommandé le retrait
définitif du marché
pourquoi le médiateur est il resté
autorisé et que le laboratoire a semé
l'envié pitié en matière de recherche je
crois qu'il est essentiel d'enrichir la
paix les connaissances sur les facteurs
précis qui favorise l'obésité afin de
concevoir des politiques de santé
publique
la science est elle en mesure
aujourd'hui de nous donner toutes les
causes
obésité le gouvernement at il
suffisamment dans entrepris des actions
de prévention acquis suffisamment
informé le public
par ailleurs il s'avère pertinent
d'explorer des approches visant
l'amélioration de la santé mais dont le
but premier n'est pas de perdre le poids
est il possible d'avoir du succès dans
le traitement de l'obésité en dehors des
remèdes qui focalise sur le régime
alimentaire obtiendront nous davantage
de succès si nous diversifions nos
cibles d'intervention
je pense aussi ici à la nutrition
précoce la nutrition pendant la
gestation et la petite enfance
influencerait la santé et le
développement ultérieur de l'enfant
suite à ce constat at on mis en oeuvre
les mesures nécessaires
de plus les travaux récents ont montré
un lien entre la qualité du microbiote
intestinal et le développement de
l'obésité une série d'expériences a
montré que des souris annexe 6 ans
microbiote intestinal résiste à
l'obésité
lorsqu'elles sont soumises à un régime
gras en revanche si les souris saines
reçoivent des bactéries intestinales de
souris obèses
elles deviennent elles-mêmes obèses où
en est-on dans ses recherches il est
primordial d'avancé au niveau de la
recherche pour pouvoir prendre des
mesures de santé publique
aujourd'hui on peut dire qu'on ne sait
pas guérir l'obésité car c'est une
maladie complexe
en effet actuellement de nos
connaissances la prévention est cruciale
il est important de ne pas devenir obèse
sinon c'est pour la vie j'insisterai
donc sur l'importance de la prévention
et je regrette que le gouvernement ne
met pas tout en oeuvre pour cette
prévention
je souhaiterais aussi attirer votre
attention sur la question de l'
équilibre nutritionnel des repas fournis
dans les cantines scolaires
l' équilibre alimentaire dans l'airé la
restauration scolaire constitue un axe
important dans la lutte contre l'obésité
car nombreux sont des enfants qui
prennent jusqu'à cinq repas par semaine
à l'école c'est d'ailleurs l'un des
objets de la loi de modernisation de
l'agriculture beauté en juillet 2010 et
dont l'article 1er impose des règles
relatives à la
qualité nutritionnelle des repas servis
dans les écoles or le 6 janvier 2011 la
commission consultative d'évaluation des
normes a donné un avis défavorable à
cette mesure cette décision est d'autant
plus regrettable que depuis dix ans de
nombreuses études ont démontré qu'en
matière de restauration scolaire le
volontariat s'avère insuffisant et que
seuls des normes d'application
obligatoire sont efficaces pour
améliorer l'équilibré nutritionnel des
plats la vie de la ccn contredit le vote
des parlementaires et les
recommandations élaborées en matière de
restauration scolaire par la direction
générale de la santé où l'heureux le
rapport de la mission d'information sur
la prévention de l'obésité
madame le ministre pouvez vous nous dire
pourquoi aujourd'hui cette disposition
se trouvent bloqués pouvez vous nous
dire à quelle date le gouvernement
compte rétablir cette mesure cruciale
sur le plan sanitaire
l'obésité est un véritable défi sociétal
mais également économique puisqu'elle
menace à terme notre système de santé
les attentes sont donc fortes vis-à-vis
de la recherche afin d'orienter les
politiques de santé publique
les attentes sont également fortes
vis-à-vis du gouvernement avant qu afin
qu'ils prennent aujourd'hui des mesures
fortes en matière de prévention car en
année en retard et il y a urgence
merci dans l'amour à chaque collègue
madame françoise laborde pour le groupe
du rassemblement démocratique social
européen
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues on est foutu on
mange trop c'est par ce refrain qu'un
chanteur populaire français dénoncé au
début des années 80 les ravages de la
malbouffe et des excès de la
consommation alimentaire de masse près
de trente années ont passé et l'obésité
toujours croissante au sein des
populations occidentales est devenu un
véritable fléau social tant sur le plan
de la santé des personnes concernées que
sur celui de ses conséquences
financières pour les comptes de la
sécurité sociale
l'obésité l'obésité c'est d'abord
l'expression du paradoxe de la modernité
qui veut que la quantité alimentaire
supplante la qualité des aliments au
détriment de l' équilibre physiologique
des consommateurs on nous avait promis
un monde d'opulence et de sources de
satiété seul apte à donner à l'homme le
bonheur individuel auquel ils aspirent
nous vivons en fait dans un
environnement où les modes de
consommation et les codes sociaux
génèrent un besoins illimités
d'accueillir d'acquérir et de consommer
adnot et un peu importe que le
consommateur y perd de sa santé peu
importe que la satiété entraîne la
frustration voire l'exclusion sociale
les chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes le
nombre d'obèses a doublé au cours des 20
dernières années dans le monde
occidental
il a même triplé pour ce qui concerne
les enfants obèses l'obésité affecte
actuellement 10% de la population adulte
en france soit 6,5 millions de personnes
dont la moitié souffrent d'obésité dite
morbide
le coût annuel de la prise en charge de
l'obésité par l'assurance maladie serait
de 4 milliards d'euros et de 10
milliards d'euros si on ajoute les 40%
de la population qui se trouve en état
de surpoids
que dire de plus si ce n'est constatée
l'urgence médico-social du phénomène
pour les individus concernés et pour la
société
je ne reviendrai pas dans le détail sur
les conséquences de cette pole
pathologie qui ont déjà été évoquées par
les précédents soit
nous sommes tous unanimes la progression
de l'obésité en particulier chez les
jeunes est un phénomène préoccupant
auquel il convient de s'atteler la
progression des régimes l'est tout
autant
en effet les périodes de restriction
alimentaire drastique sont maintenant
dénoncée par le corps médical comme des
facteurs aggravants aboutissant à des
courbes de poids dit en yo yo sé
succession de régimes installe le
surpoids et l'obésité
aussi sûrement que l'anarchie
alimentaire il est donc particulièrement
inquiétant de constater que 65 % de la
population déclarent avoir déjà fait un
régime
les facteurs concourant cette situation
sont multiples culturelles économiques
sociaux ou encore médicaux abstraction
faite du déterminisme génétique propre à
chaque individu
les modes de consommation alimentaire
ont une large part de responsabilité à
travers sa banalisation dans le corpus
social l'obésité demeure l'expression la
plus visible de l'état de dépression
collective dans lequel baignent les
sociétés de consommation occidentale et
la société française ne fait
malheureusement pas exception
sédentarité stress anxiété pollution
publicités agressives sont autant de
facteurs déclenchants ou aggravantes
chacun d'entre eux renvoie l'image d'une
société où l'individu du roi souffre et
meurt de ne manquer de rien et d'avoir
besoin de tout l'obésité nous interroge
sur nos choix sont nos choix sociétaux
et notre vision du monde
elle pourrait incarner le paradoxe qui
oppose un occident riche prospère mais
malade à d'autres sociétés
économiquement pauvre politiquement
instable où les émeutes de la faim
viennent régulièrement nous rappeler que
l'europe et les états unis à eux seuls
consomme près de 80% de la richesse
mondiale
malheureusement la prévalence de
l'obésité commencent à augmenter
y compris dans les pays les moins riches
cette nouvelle tendance nous rappelle la
responsabilité des groupes industriels
de
agroalimentaire dans la progression de
ce fléau et de leurs méthodes marketing
bien rodée dans un environnement très
peu réglementé dès lors comment inverser
la tendance comment faire pour que nos
enfants ne soient plus les victimes
désignées de nos propres excès la
progression des addictions est une
question rarement soulevée mais qui
mérite d'être posée car elle nécessite
une réflexion sur de grandes questions
existentielles fondamentale la recherche
du plaisir et la peur de la mort la
frontière entre le plaisir et l'excès la
santé la maladie le culturellement
acceptables et le médicament nécessaire
est souvent très difficile à trouver en
particulier dans notre pays où la
gastronomie est un patrimoine culturel
un élément vient compliquer davantage la
tâche des personnes en surpoids
c'est une lapalissade mais je rappelle
que pour vivre il est possible de
s'arrêter de fumer de boire de l'alcool
ou encore de se droguer
mais pas d'arrêter de manger c'est pour
tenter de répondre à ce défi que
l'office parlementaire d'évaluation des
choix scientifiques et technologiques a
dressé un bilan exhaustif et détaillée
de l'état de la recherche en matière
d'obésité
je tiens d'ailleurs à saluer le
remarquable travail effectué par notre
collègue brigitte bout rapporteur de
l'office dont les conclusions mérite
l'attention particulière de notre
assemblée
le rapport met en exergue deux types de
recherche en amont par le biais d'une
recherche scientifique et médicale qui
traite l'obésité comme toute autre
pathologie physiologique en aval par des
méthodes préventives susceptible
d'empêcher ou de freiner les
comportements à risque et d'améliorer
notre environnement quotidien
je resterai le choix mes collègues
médecins de s'attarder davantage sur les
nombreux aspects de la recherche
médicale
concernant la prévention de l'obésité je
pense qu on ne soulignera jamais assez
la nécessité d'appréhender le mal à la
racine par l'apprentissage de la
modération et de l'equilibre chez nos
enfants alors que toutes les enquêtes de
consommation pointe du doigt l'excès de
consommation en sucre en dépit des
efforts de communication réalisée
par les pouvoirs publics sur les risques
liés au surpoids nos enfants demeurent
les cibles privilégiées des marques de
produits à forte teneur calorique
c'est pourquoi depuis plusieurs années
le parlement a fait preuve d'imagination
et d'audace pour tenter d'endiguer cette
tendance ce fut notamment le cas lors de
l'adoption de la loi relative à la
politique de santé publique du 9 août
2004 interdisant la présence dans tous
les établissements scolaires de
distributeurs automatiques de boissons
et de produits alimentaires payant est
accessible aux élèves
on pourrait citer aussi la taxe sur les
boissons sucrées proposé par notre
collègue alain vasselle voté au sénat
lors des débats relatifs à la loi de
financement de sécurité sociale pour
2008 mais qui n'a jamais franchi
hélas le cap de la commission mixte
paritaire de décembre 2007
rappelons aussi qu'un rapport
parlementaire de 2008 préconisait une
augmentation de la tva sur les produits
de grignotage et de snacking
qu'en est il aujourd'hui bref tout le
monde s'accorde à penser qu'il est
impératif d'éloigner les plus jeunes des
tentations d'un marketing d'autant plus
offensif et néfaste qu'il ne profite
qu'à des entreprises pour la plupart
multinationales avant tout soucieuse de
gagner des parts de marché
cela peut revêtir plusieurs formes de
l'interdiction de spots télévisuels à
certaines heures à la mise en place de
nouveaux programmes pédagogiques au sein
des établissements scolaires sous forme
d'ateliers gastronomique éducatif par
exemple le législateur a entre les mains
suffisamment d'éléments pour proposer
une panneaux mis une panoplie complète
de mesures clés l'aubade l'obésité ne
doit plus être un tabou ni même un sujet
de seconde catégorie
bien au contraire la combattre doit être
un moyen des objectifs prioritaires de
santé publique voire une cause nationale
l'homme politique homme d'action par
nature est toujours impatient que la
science lui offre la connaissance des
moyens et des conséquences mais il sait
à l'avant ce que la science ne le
délivrera jamais de l'obligation de
choisir parce que les cultures sont
multiples et les valeurs sociales
parfois contradictoires
pour toutes ces raisons il nous
appartient mes chers collègues de
choisir l'efficacité et la prévention la
prise de conscience de la gravité de ce
fléau est un premier pas mais madame la
ministre nous devons désormais faire en
sorte que davantage de moyens soient
mobilisés pour développer la matte la
recherche en matière d'obésité avant que
ce mal des temps modernes se répande
davantage je vous remercie
si mme asha collègues la parole est à
madame catherine dumas au titre de
l'union pour un mouvement populaire
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je souhaite
souligner à l'occasion de ce débat
l'importance de l'éducation au goût et
la promotion des bonnes pratiques
alimentaires en particulier auprès du
jeune public
comme beaucoup d'entre vous mes chers
collègues je suis particulièrement
attaché à ne pas stigmatiser les
produits en tant que tel mais plutôt à
informer les consommateurs sur les
bienfaits d'une alimentation variée et
équilibrée
plusieurs initiatives en ce sens ont vu
le jour ces dernières années et s'engage
résolument dans la voie de la promotion
d'une consommation responsable et
raisonnée je pense notamment aux
formidables outils que constitue la
convention signée le 18 février 2009 en
installant la charte alimentaire
télévisuelle les précédentes expériences
d'interdiction de la publicité à
destination des enfants n'ont en effet
jamais été très probante le choix
audacieux et très pragmatique
d'encourager l'information et la
sensibilisation en matière
d'alimentation et d'associer à ce
programme d'action l'ensemble des
acteurs concernés doit donc être salué
piloté par le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel en particulier sous
l'impulsion de christine kelly qui
préside la mission santé et
développement durable cette charte
comporte deux volets très
complémentaires
tout d'abord elle fixe et renforce les
règles de déontologie qui s'applique aux
annonceurs pour le contenu de leurs
messages publicitaires
parallèlement elle les associés à la
production de programmes courts
informatif à destination des enfants
diffusée au total près de 400 fois sur
une quinzaine de chaînes en 2010
cette politique très volontariste semble
aujourd'hui porter ses fruits
la participation active la
responsabilisation des différents
partenaires est à ce jour une réussite
un rapport a donc été remis en juin 2010
à la ministre de la santé
il souligne d'ailleurs sa parfaite
application cette initiative française
unique ans
europe est applaudie par la commission
européenne plusieurs pays voisins eux
aussi confrontés à l'augmentation de
l'obésité envisage même de s'inspirer de
cette expérience et de mettre en place
des partenariats similaires
au vu de cette première expérience
réussie je pense donc que nous devons
comme pour de nombreuses autres
questions de santé publique
privilégier l'éducation la prévention
dès le plus jeune âge plutôt que les
interdictions et restrictions excessives
notre collègue anne marie payet l'a
d'ailleurs très bien dit il y à quelques
minutes au sein du club parlementaire de
la table française que j'ai l'honneur de
coprésider avec deux autres collègues
parlementaires qui réunit plus de 330
députés et sénateurs de tout département
et de toutes appartenances politiques
nous sommes donc très attachés la
promotion de l'éducation au goût dans ce
cadre l'inscription récente du repas des
français au patrimoine immatériel de
l'unesco peut en effet servir de sursaut
pour une prise de conscience collective
prendre son repas assis à table
consacrer du temps aux repas consommé
des fruits variés des produits variés
faire du déjeuner ou du dîner un moment
de lien social et un moment de partage
ses valeurs très positives sont des
composantes essentielles de notre
identité alimentaire et contribue donc
intrinsèquement à lutter contre les
mauvais comportements
la transmission de ce patrimoine commun
la défense de ses spécificités constitue
en soit la plus simple et la plus
efficace politique de prévention
elles placent d'ailleurs la france parmi
les pays industrialisés les moins
affectés par les problèmes d'obésité
avec mes collègues et membres du club
nous entendons donc resté 13 très
attentif aux orientations qui vont être
prises sur cet important sujet de santé
publique qui engage bien sûr l'avenir de
nos générations futures
je voudrais d'ailleurs à cet effet
remercier notre collègue brigitte bout
grâce à qui ce débat peut avoir lieu
aujourd'hui et vous remercier également
madame la ministre d'apporter bien sûr
la contribution du gouvernement sur ce
sujet et je suis certaine mes chers
collègues que ce sujet pour à nous
rassembler
bien au delà des clivages politiques si
mme asha collègues
la parole est un monsieur alain
chatillon rattaché au groupe peu de
l'union pour un mouvement populaire
voilà ma présidente madame la ministre
chers collègues comme vous savez la
surcharge pondérale et l'obésité ont
effectivement connu une hausse
spectaculaire au sein de la population
adulte européenne en europe 1 adulte sur
deux est en surpoids un sur six est
obèse
la france compte 20 millions de
personnes en surpoids et donc une partie
en obèses
en france une étude de l'irdes des
instituts de recherche et documentation
en économie de la santé sur ces données
2002 situent le taux d'obésité entre 1,5
et 4 6% des dépenses de santé
la consommation moyenne de choix et de
biens médicaux d'une personne obèse
s'élèverait aujourd'hui environ 2500
euros soit le double de celle d'un
individu de l'obèse selon cette étude la
dépense de santé liés à l'obésité
atteindrait 2,6 milliards d'euros et
pour l'assurance maladie
200 milliards d'euros l'obésité s'avère
joué un rôle central dans le
développement d'une série de maladies
comme ça a été dit par mes prédécesseurs
maladies chroniques le diabète type 2
non insulinodépendant mais également
plus de 80% des diabètes sont liées à
l'obésité l'hypertension artérielle les
maladies cardiovasculaires mais aussi
certains cancers et des maladies
respiratoires et articulaires source de
handicap
la lutte contre l'obésité et le surpoids
est devenu une priorité en europe et
dans tous les pays de l'union les
politiques de santé publique doivent
considérer le problème à sa base
c'est en traitant le surpoids que l'on
pourra endiguer la déferlante de
l'obésité en effet les études ont
démontré que les sujets atteints de
surcharge pondérale avait 90% de chances
de développer une obésité lens c'est à
dire la jante nationale de sécurité
sanitaire
r de l'alimentation de l'environnement
et du travail a publié le 12 mai son
avis relatif aux pratiques de régimes à
visée amaigrissante ses conclusions dans
nous alerter dans la mesure où l'on
côtoie le pire et le meilleur
et nous amener à tirer une série de
conclusions concernant la recherche pour
lutter contre l'obésité et pour
améliorer le contrôle du poids
l'alertent nous on est très vigilants
face aux discours qui véhicule une image
faussée du corps la communication les
actions de prévention de l'obésité
doivent être ciblées sur les personnes à
risque celle sur les enjeux de la perte
de poids aussi des actions tous azimuts
ont souvent des effets contre productifs
et cela à moyen terme
en poussant des populations normale à
s'engager dans des pratiques
alimentaires à risque pour tenter
d'atteindre une image idéalisée du corps
l'avis de lens établies notamment les
conséquences néfastes de régime
fantaisiste basé sur des privations ou
des exclusions et qui ne sont pas des
actes anodins en particulier pour que
les populations sensibles
les adolescentes les femmes enceintes
les personnes âgées ces régimes
fantaisiste entraîne une reprise rapide
du poids et parfois d'autres
conséquences néfastes plus ou moins
graves pour la santé
la réponse d'eads évidemment pas dans le
laisser-aller et la vie de lens permet
d'avancer sur les mesures qu'il
conviendrait de promouvoir la première
conclusion c'est qu'il faut favoriser
madame la ministre et faire progresser
la recherche sur des régimes sérieux
scientifiquement fondées sur la perte et
le contrôle du poids nous avons de
grands laboratoires de recherche publics
dont la réputation est désormais
internationale mais nous avons aussi
d'autres atouts
la france a une position industrielle
forte sur les marchés de l'alimentation
spécifiques avec des entreprises qui
sont capables de développer une
recherche adaptées aux besoins
particuliers d'une population qui
cherchent à perdre à contrôler son poids
c'est un atout important sur lequel nous
pouvons nous appuyer
les équipes de recherche existent les
connaissances sur ce sujet sont
accessibles nous ne partons pas d'un
désert scientifique
la deuxième conclusion si ma première
conclusion relève d'un effort de
recherche qui doit être portée par des
professionnels ma deuxième conclusion
relève davantage du rôle du législateur
il s'agit de créer un environnement
juridique propice à la recherche et au
développement de produits permettant de
répondre aux problématiques de perte et
de contrôle du poids
quelle est la situation actuelle il
existe aujourd'hui une directive-cadre
au niveau communautaire pour les
produits alimentaires diététique
celle ci offrant un cadre adéquat dans
la mesure où il est à la fois très
contraignant pour les entreprises du
secteur mais aussi protecteur pour les
entreprises qui ont accepté de se hisser
à ce niveau de contrainte en termes de
sécurité du consommateur et de qualité
cette norme européenne a également
influencé la construction des normes
mondiales
je pense ici au codex alimentarius et a
permis de faire des produits européens
une référence dans les pays tiers
passant au degré d'exigence cette
directive a aussi encouragé les
entreprises à investir dans la recherche
d'abord pour atteindre et conserver le
niveau nécessaire mais ensuite pour
développer des produits plus efficaces
cette situation satisfaisante tant du
point de vue de la recherche que du
développement notre industrie sur la
réponse à un problème de société de plus
en plus important or cette législation
européenne repose sur une évaluation
scientifique des risques qui date de
1990 elle demande donc bien évidemment à
être mise à jour à la lumière des
évolutions des comportements
alimentaires mais aussi des projets des
progrès de la recherche
il est nécessaire de continuer à assurer
à travers un cadre européen commun au
niveau d'exigence vis-à-vis des produits
destinés au contrôle ou à la perte de
poids
faute de quoi l'europe sera envahie de
produits plus ou moins bon marché vendus
sur internet ou dans des circuits divers
qui n'offriront pas la moindre garantie
fondement sur une recherche appliquée la
principale incitation à la recherche
pour les entreprises c'est de pouvoir
valoriser le fruit de plusieurs années
d'investissements financiers et des
forts de leur équipe de chercheurs il
faut que le cadre légal que nous leur
offrons donne un avantage à des
entreprises qui jouent le jeu de la
recherche de la sécurité et de la
qualité
face à des intervenants qui propose des
miroirs aux alouettes pour des personnes
dont le désir d'améliorer l'image de
leur corps est d'autant plus puissants
que les médias transmettre une image
faussée du corps humain ma dernière
conclusion il me semble que notre rôle
est de tous et la commission européenne
a proposé une nouvelle version cette
directive cadre sur les produits
diététiques
l'enjeu n'est passé certes c'est
nécessairement de communiquer à tout va
vers le grand public sur la question de
l'obésité
cela peut même s'avérer contre-productif
dans certains cas l'enjeu c'est plutôt
de cibler les personnes à risque et de
mettre à leur disposition les moyens de
changer leurs comportements alimentaires
et d'assurer un contrôle du poids
durable il convient de développer la
recherche appliquée pour proposer aux
personnes qui sont et qui ont réellement
besoin de ces outils adaptés d'où la
nécessité de créer un cadre favorable au
développement de ses outils
alors chers collègues je vous propose
que nous votions une résolution en
faveur d'une remise à jour de la
directive européenne que je viens
d'évoquer spécifique aux produits pour
régime amaigrissant
je vous remercie de votre compréhension
mais attention nous avons une industrie
qui a de la vence dans ce domaine qui
est très réglementé essayons de faire en
sorte que véritablement au niveau
européen nous ayons les moyens de nous
exprimer et au delà d'avoir une
politique rigoureuse en matière de santé
particulièrement sur le point de
l'amaigrissement
merci madame la ministre et mes chers
collègues et chaque collègue
la parole est maintenant un madame
valérie pécresse ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
madame la présidente madame la
rapporteure chère brigitte bout mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs avant toutes
choses permettez moi de vous dire que je
me réjouis tout particulièrement que
l'office parlementaire d'évaluation des
choix scientifiques et technologiques
est inscrit à l'ordre du jour de la
haute assemblée un débat sur l'état de
la recherche en matière d'obésité
grâce aux travaux approfondis conduit
par le rapporteur brigitte bout nous
disposons désormais d'une analyse qui
j'en suis certaine fera référence sur le
sujet la très grande qualité des
conclusions que vous avez présenté
madame le sénateur offre un excellent
point d'appui à nos discussions
comme elles ne manqueront pas
d'alimenter la réflexion collective tout
au long des mois qui viennent vous
l'avez vous même souligné l'obésité est
un fléau social
un fléau social qui progresse lentement
mais de façon inéluctable semble-t-il ce
sont vos mots et je veux dire à votre
assemblée que naturellement je partage
le constat que vous venez de dresser les
chiffres sont suffisamment alarmant pour
qu'on les rappelle
l'obésité chez les adultes français
augmente de 5 9% par an elle touche
désormais plus de 15% de nos
compatriotes et 16 % des enfants sont en
surpoids ou obèses soit quatre fois plus
qu'il ya 50 ans les conséquences sont
particulièrement lourdes est
préoccupante tant sur le plan sanitaire
avec la recrudescence des diabète les
maladies cardiovasculaires et ou de
certains cancers que sur le plan social
et psychologique avec les
discriminations et les stigmatisations
que l'obésité peut entraîner j'ajoute
que nos concitoyens ne sont pas égaux
devant cette maladie qui fera beaucoup
plus largement est beaucoup plus
durement les catégories les plus
défavorisées de la population
vous l'avez donc dit de manière très
pertinente
l'obésité n'est pas un mal
spécifiquement français mais
contrairement à ce qui a pu longtemps
être dit ou écrit
c'est un mal qui
a fini par toucher effectivement la
france au même titre et dans les mêmes
proportions que les autres pays
européens pourtant d'apparence bien
connu est installé dans les consciences
collectives
le développement de cette pathologie
reste très mal compris mal compris quant
à ses causes bien sûr mais aussi mal
compris quant à la manière de le traiter
ou de le prévenir
la raison de ce paradoxe tient une
raison simple ce paradoxe pardon tient à
une raison simple
jusqu'aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas fait
de l'obésité un objet d'étude à part
entière en tout cas pas au même niveau
d'exigence et de rigueur scientifique
que nous l'avons fait pour d'autres
maladies
l'obésité est en effet une pathologie
une pathologie que nous peinons encore
non seulement à traiter mais à
reconnaître comme tel car nous nous
faisons trop souvent de l'obésité une
représentation sommaire voire simpliste
ou g2 beaucoup cette maladie mal
comprises apparaît comme le fruit d'un
simple déséquilibre d'un côté
l'abondance alimentaire et avec elle la
tentation de trop ou de mal manger et de
l'autre la sédentarité qui accompagne la
vie urbaine et la tertiarisation de
l'économie
avec à la clé l'idée qu'il suffirait
d'une simple discipline individuelle
pour permettre de rééquilibrer la
balance apports nutritionnels dépense
calorique et c'est bien cette vision
d'une obésité qui serait tout à la fois
à mal social mais surtout le signe d'une
faiblesse de la volonté propre à
l'individu qui triomphe
lorsque nous qualifions
d'américanisation le quasi-doublement de
la proportion d'obèses dans la
population française
en un peu plus de dix ans cette vision
un peu simpliste
nous devons aujourd'hui nous libérer
pour nous donner les moyens de
comprendre le bézy thé et de prévenir
efficacement ses formes pathologique car
il n'y a pas une mais des obésités que
nous devons apprendre à distinguer
soigneusement de la même manière qu'il
n'y a pas une cause unique mais des
causes multiples à l'apparition de cette
pathologie
car l'obésité est pour une part une
maladie sociale certes mais c'est aussi
une pathologie comportementale qui met
en jeu des prédispositions génétiques et
aussi des mécanismes physiologiques
toutes les formes d'obésité ne met pas
en jeu ces différents facteurs
de la même manière c'est pour cela que
l' approche nutritionnelle authier aussi
essentiel soit elle ne peut pas être
l'alpha et l'oméga de l'analyse
scientifique de l'obésité comme toutes
les approches d'un phénomène complexe
elle a vocation à se combiner avec
toutes les autres pour nous offrir une
vision complète et approfondie du
surpoids et de l'obésité
c'est précisément dans cet esprit que le
président de la république a lancé un
vaste chantier autour de l'obésité pour
rassembler l'ensemble de nos forces de
recherche concernés par cette pathologie
et nous donner toutes les chances de
mieux la comprendre pour demain mieux la
traiter et mieux la prévenir
vous m'avez à plusieurs reprises
interrogé sur l'état d'avancement du
plan obésité annoncé il ya un an
maintenant par le président de la
république et dont la présidence a été
confiée au professeur arnaud basdevant
eh bien je vais vous dire d'abord que
les différents ministères concernés ont
défini une stratégie commune et
collabore efficacement depuis plusieurs
mois déjà le cadre du programme national
alimentation piloté par le ministère de
l'agriculture et du plan national
nutrition santé
3 orchestrée lui par le ministère de la
santé
certains axes du plan obésité
bénéficient d'ores et déjà de l'action
du gouvernement
je pense en particulier aux mesures
mises en oeuvre pour améliorer la
qualité de l'offre alimentaire et
l'accès
une bonne alimentation c'est le cas par
exemple vous là vous l'avez demandé des
restaurants universitaires ou mon
ministère propose des campagnes de
communication mais aussi les ateliers
cuisine avec le crous par exemple au
titre de la seule recherche
le premier temps fort de ce plan obésité
fut l'organisation
les 24 et 25 mars dernier d'un colloque
exceptionnel qui a réuni autour du
professeur arnaud basdevant dont je
tenais à saluer l'exceptionnel travail
des chercheurs et les experts venus de
l'ensemble des champs du savoir de la
recherche biomédicale à la génétique et
aux neurosciences en passant par les
sciences humaines et sociales
c'était la première fois en france
qu'une concertation scientifiques aussi
large été tenus sur une telle pathologie
de ces heures de réflexion commune est
née une vision profondément renouvelée
de l'obésité aboutissant à trente
propositions d'actions prioritaires qui
consacre ensemble l'importance décisif
de la transdisciplinarité car pour
comprendre l'évolution des maladies
chroniques comme l'obésité
nous devons être capables de prendre en
compte l'ensemble des déterminants
sociaux et individuels des décisions et
des comportements qui ont cours tout au
long du développement de la pathologie
et cela d'autant plus que les facteurs
génétiques
je les dis physiologique
environnementaux comportementaux non
seulement s'additionnent mais ne cesse
d'interagir entre eux est de former des
systèmes qui pourraient être mis en
lumière suppose de forger de nouveaux
concepts de nouvelles méthodes et les
instruments commun l'analyse c'est
pourquoi je me réjouis tout
particulièrement
quelle issue de ce colloque des
collaboration féconde et vu le jour
je pense en particulier aux groupes de
travail qui ont été mis en place entre
les différents instituts de recherche de
nos deux alliances de recherche
thématique dans le domaine de la santé
mais aussi dans le domaine des sciences
humaines et sociales
l'alliance avis ann et l'alliance at
elle un ensemble de chercheurs ont tracé
les contours de programmes scientifiques
conjoints au carrefour de la biologie de
l'imagerie médicale et les
sciences humaines et sociales d'autres
projets de recherche verront bientôt le
jour en économie en sociologie en
psychologie sociale
l'analyse des effets des campagnes
d'information santé publique par exemple
sur les comportements de consommation en
sera une des priorités des études en
lien étroit avec les enjeux de
prévention et les différentes
propositions que vous avez soulevé
thaler madame le sénateur
concernant par exemple la publicité à la
télévision sur différents médias
vous avez parlé de la charte du conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel
je vous indique que cette question sera
traitée dans le plan national nutrition
santé pour réfléchir à son évolution
madame la sénatrice vous m'avez
également interrogé sur al ihsan
l'alliance pour la lier la santé et ce à
la fondation
et bien je peux d'ores et déjà vous dire
que le deuxième temps fort du plan
présidentiel sera la création avant la
fin de l'année d'une fondation
scientifique consacrée entièrement à
l'obésité
porté par l'alliance avis ann elle
permettra de coordonner l'ensemble de
nos programmes de recherche comme ce que
j'évoquais à l'instant et de mettre en
oeuvre les actes et les priorités
stratégiques définis dans le cadre du
plan en matière de recherche l'obésité
la transdisciplinarité doit devenir la
règle et c'est pourquoi je compte
beaucoup sur ces futurs partenariats au
sein de la fondation pour élargir autant
que faire se peut le champ des
collaborations entre nos différents
chercheurs
au delà du plan présidentiel qui permet
de fédérer nos forces de recherche
je souhaitais procédé devant vous un
rapide état des lieux de nos programmes
de recherche consacrés à l'obésité et
des moyens qui leur sont réservées dans
le cadre des financements courant prévus
par l' agence nationale de la recherche
de nombreux appels d'offres concerne
naturellement l'obésité que ce soit au
titre des programmes biologie santé ou
du programme eco systèmes et
développement durable parmi les plus
ambitieux je pense aux appels pnra du
programme national de recherche en
alimentation et nutrition et alia
alimentation et industries alimentaires
j'ajoute que d'autres projets
scientifiques
parmi les plus remarquables ont été
retenus dans le cadre de la
programmation blanche de la nr c'est à
dire la programmation qui finance des
projets totalement créatif conçu par nos
chercheurs eux mêmes
au total ce sont près de 22 millions
d'euros qui entre 2005 et 2010 sont
allés à la recherche sur l'obésité et
nous sommes donc un des premiers
contributeurs européens dans ce domaine
avec le plan d'investissements d'avenir
qui va consacrer vous savez 22 milliards
d'euros à l'enseignement à la recherche
et à l'innovation des perspectives bien
plus vaste encore s'ouvre désormais à
nous car une vaste part de cet argent
ira à la recherche médicale et dans la
première vague d'appels à projets on
voit qu'on les ambitions de chercheurs
en matière de lutte contre l'obésité
sont tout à fait remarquables
j'en veux pour meilleure preuve le
projet d'institut hospitalo
universitaires qui vient de voir le jour
li a chu aykan qui donnera naissance à
un véritable pôle international de
recherche et de soins sur les maladies
cardio métaboliques comme le diabète les
insuffisances cardiaques et l'obésité
donc il sera situé comme vous le savez à
paris à la salpêtrière et il unira les
expertises scientifiques et médicales
des équipes de l'université pierre et
marie curie et de l'hôpital
cette ia chu permettra l'émergence d'un
véritable continuum de recherche et de
soins du laboratoire jusqu au chevet des
patients tel qu'il fut présentée par les
chercheurs eux mêmes lors de leur
candidature aux investissements d'avenir
l'objectif de l'ia chu et de faire
basculer la recherche sur l'obésité et
les maladies cardiovasculaires dans
l'ère de la médecine prédictive et de
prendre en charge les patients à
l'échelle de leur vie tout entière
depuis l'identification des
susceptibilités individuel jusqu'aux
traitements des récidives et des
complications en passant par la
prévention et le diagnostic précoce sur
le plan clinique
cela se traduira par des traitements
personnalisés adaptés aux déterminants
génétiques mais aussi psychologiques
sociaux des malades
c'est dire les espoirs immenses que nous
fondons aujourd'hui sur ce projet
exceptionnel qui sera demain le fleuron
de la recherche française en matière
d'obésité
deux autres projets de tout premier plan
ont été retenus dans le cadre des
investissements d'avenir
le projet ligue en tout d'abord au titre
des équipements d'excellence
il misera sur le séquençage à très haut
débit pour mieux comprendre le rôle que
jouent certains gènes dans le
développement des maladies chroniques
comme la maladie d'alzheimer ou
l'obésité
nous quittons l'hémicycle du sénat merci
à vous d'avoir suivi en partie ce débat
consacré à la lutte contre l'obésité
à suivre preuve par 3 l'émission
politique de la rédaction de public
sénat
avec ce soir comme invité et benoist
apparu secrétaire d'état au logement
très bonne fin de journée à tous